I'm vegan I'm vegan I'm vegan I'm vegan
I'm vegan vegan I'm vegan but I'm not
judging you when you eat a cheeseburger
in front of me I'm vegan but I don't
think I'm better than you I'm vegan but
I'm not radicalized I'm not gonna throw
red paint on your fur coat I'm vegan but
I'm not against killing animals for food
but I'm not lacking protein or nutrients
but I'm not weak or skinny but I'm not a
health nut no salads here
but I'm not eating bland nasty food I'm
vegan but my diet doesn't define all of
who I am I'm vegan and I'm a bodybuilder
and a Mexican and I still eat way too
much pizza I'm vegan and I am my hippie
and I really believe in the impact that
it has on climate change and I'm an
adventurous foodie I'm vegan and I eat
pizzas cheese burgers hot dogs donuts
ice cream everything I'm vegan and I'm
not afraid to represent initially for
health reasons in my family high blood
pressure high cholesterol strokes
thyroid disorder I want to do something
to change my life to do something
different than my ancestors have done
and see if there's a different outcome
for me I would have vegan first and
foremost for animal rights the
environment and my health about four and
a half years ago I decided to go vegan
because I was in a really dark place and
I was trying to research different ways
that I could help myself feel better
naturally it's something that I really
really believe in these days it never
feels like a diet it never feels like a
restriction it actually feels very
empowering to be able to say no it's
about doing your best to make conscious
decisions to do right by the animals the
environment and your body as best as you
can
[Music]